plenty of great receivers in this year's
draft how many will go in round one the
chris sims unbuttoned mock draft has
four receivers taken between picks eight
and twenty one the pft mock draft which
i had absolutely nothing to do in the
compilation of although i will take the
credit if it ends up being even remotely
right
starting at number 11 and lasting all
the way until number 29. seven would be
a record mgm it would tie a record 2004.
mgm has the over under at five and a
half receivers drafted in round one
obviously chris would take the under i
would take the over
uh
and you know here's the challenge
with so many receivers
available throughout the whole process
and eric
the ravens gm said not that long ago
that you can find a starter in round
five you got to really love a guy to use
a first round pick on them it's almost
like the running back dynamic why do you
burn a first round pick on a running
back when there's going to be plenty of
them available later chris well that's
exactly right i mean i think that's
where ultimately i why i only went with
the four wide receivers because i went
to go okay wait
will this team right here take another
receiver
or will they take a defensive tackle and
i you know my common you know notion
that i came to more times than not is
you're going to have a if you take the
defensive tackle you're going to have a
much greater chance of getting a
receiver that's still really good in the
second round and i can't say the same
thing vice versa about that situation to
where you went okay that team takes the
receiver and i'm going to sit there and
go oh i don't know if there's going to
be a defensive tackle worth the damn
there for you at the second round at
least to the level you like so that is
the big discussion of this first round
mike you know and and just to your your
mock draft just you know the the one the
two guys brandon iowa from arizona state
when i got done with my mock i went
there i it bothered me all night you
know one one of our producers pete demo
little analeta lettuce right i sent him
texts like man it annoys me i don't have
ioc in the first round i think he's on
the cusp there i really do but
ultimately uh i i think you're going to
see another huge run on receivers in the
second round
i think every every time you say pete's
name you add another syllable it keeps
getting bigger and longer and longer
yeah and and that's the that's the
challenge and you know the human dynamic
here also is
once the run starts
you
you fear that you're not going to get
that guy that maybe you think you'll get
later so you jump into it it becomes a
feeding frenzy hey if we want to upgrade
the position we can't play games here we
got to go get the guy we like who cares
if there's going to be other competent
receivers later this is the guy we like
this is the guy we want and this is one
of the challenges this year chris
because
the absence of the pro day workouts the
inability of the scouts and the coaches
and gm's to come together and trade
information and and also maybe be a
little loose-lipped because you're
trying to preserve the relationship with
that guy who works for the other team in
case you get whacked after the draft and
you're gonna be looking for a job i mean
there's all sorts of different
motivations that come into play but when
you don't have those little mini
conventions at oklahoma and alabama and
michigan and ohio state and here and
there and there and there where they're
all getting together and they're all
running into each other we don't have
that consensus that you usually have and
so the mock drafts are all over the
place because nobody really knows who's
in love with whom and that's one of the
things we're going to find out tonight
well no and you're right and you know
also to the fact mike with these
receivers there's so many good ones and
so many different types of good ones
right so it's going to be beauty in the
eye of the beholder you know there's
some teams that are looking at it and go
oh man i love this receiver his size is
special another team's going to look at
a receiver and go man i love his smaller
guy his quickness his jitterbug ability
to do those type of things so you know
mike you know the the big thing to me
the three receivers that are i think at
least are in play for that first round
conversation you got two of them on
there brandon ayo michael pittman jr t
higgins those will be the three guys to
me i don't think leviska channel is a
first round talent i could be wrong uh
but either way those are the three
receivers that jump out to me
i i would if i'm a betting man i would
obviously take the under you know again
i think that offensive tackles
defensive tackles the really good ones
they're going to be at a premium here
and i think people are going to make
more of a play for them when we get into
the 20s than they will the receivers
because of what you already said there's
just there's going to be an abundance of
them to be there to be had in the second
and third round
even though the cardinals have acquired
deandre hopkins for a second round pick
plus a running back they no longer
wanted to pay in david johnson
the cardinals taking cd lamb at eight
overall you spoke to lamb yesterday and
asked him point blank about his former
oklahoma teammate kyler murray stumping
for the cardinals to take him what did
lamb have to say about that well i think
he'd be very excited about the prospects
of that first off to re-ignite you know
his his connection with k1 as he calls
him okay i learned that yesterday from
cd lamb it's k1 that's how we talk about
kyler murray but i think he loves kyla
murray of course he knows the offense
mike and he's he's ultimately excited
because he views himself as a very
similar player as deandre hopkins and
then the ability to learn from deandre
hopkins and larry fitzgerald i mean he
lit up with the idea of that mike
you know this is one i didn't think
about you know i was dabbling with my
mock draft leading up to the leading up
to the release of it and everything like
that
and i had somebody who i i trust who
said there's a common notion around the
nfl going around right now that you know
the arizona cardinals they might just go
golden state on everybody on the
offensive side of the ball we got a
quarterback that's 4-3 we're going to
spread the field out we got kenyan drake
next to our quarterback he could spread
out as a receiver or just be a guy that
comes out of the backfield and then we
got hopkins cd lamb and larry fitzgerald
and i'll miss it uh you know the other
kid they got andy isabella too andy
isabella the kid they yeah go who's the
other john kirk
i mean they are loaded at receiver
they'd have to move somebody if they get
cd lamb you don't have enough spots on
the field they're gonna put some weight
on one of these guys i'm gonna play
tight ender tackle for crying out loud
you've got fitzgerald hopkins andy
isabella christian kirk and then you add
cd lamb to that i it's it's uh it's mine
i understand hey it gives you maximum
weapons
yeah well yeah and it's it's the same
conversation we have we're talking about
with like oh the chiefs might trade for
henry ruggs
i mean hey cardinals i don't think this
is a dumb idea to go to cd lamb first
off larry fitzgerald this is it right i
mean maybe another year after this so
it's not like you're gonna have him
forever and maybe they do trade one of
those two guys but every play is three
or four wide receiver sets for cliff
kingsbury and if you want to sell
tickets and be exciting and do all that
man you know cd lamb is the ultimate in
space wide receiver in this draft he is
like alan iverson he will cross you over
and break your ankles when he has the
ball in his hands he is special the
first guy never tackles them so that to
me you know i they they might take that
approach if you got a quarterback like
that you you hired a head coach that's
famous for his offensive shootout
mentality
you know why not just say hey you want
to play us the arizona cardinals you
better be ready to score some points
because we're going to make this attract
me and i don't think it's the craziest
idea i've ever heard
there still is no multi-ball option in
football although that was one of those
theories that david letterman used to
trot out from time to time whenever you
talk about the nfl that you score a
touchdown or something like that you
should be allowed to use a second ball
they'll need more than one football if
they have c.d lamb and larry fitzgerald
and andy isabella deandre hopkins and
christian kirk and i think kirk are so
and i've seen some steam that maybe kirk
ends up on the move and this would
explain it if they get lamb all right we
got to take a break will a running back
be drafted at all tonight we'll look at
some more draft props when pft live
continues right after this
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports